a lot of the stories that you have on
here I I relate to and I've been through
myself so it's like and it's just so
cool somebody actually discussing these
things because they need to be talked
about but no one ever
does I
agree so Josh where you from originally
where'd you grow up I'm from Los Angeles
I was born and raised in West
Hollywood
uh spent uh yeah quite a bit of um uh
time early uh on like when I was a kid
um my my mother and father didn't you
know they had a very strange
relationship my my dad was 17 and my mom
was 26 when she got pregnant something
like that so needless to say he wasn't
ready to be a father and he wasn't
really a very nice
person uh anyway you know he split when
I was three and I didn't really hear
back from him until I was about
17 uh so it was just my mom my brother
and
I uh was a little hectic sometimes a
little bit uh crazy uh my
mom was struggling quite a bit um she
initially got accepted into UCLA when
she was 18 and was going to go to school
um but then like she kind of put it off
for a little while and then she got
accepted and again and uh then she got
pregnant and so after she had me she was
going to go back but then she got
pregnant again with my brother and and
um so and then my father left and that
kind of put a damper on her
plans so uh we spent a lot of my my
early years like staying um with family
uh in East LA which was kind of rough I
was like um very different neighborhood
yeah I was one of the only white kids uh
with long blonde hair that went to my
school and uh yeah I got bullied a lot
like a lot when when I was in
school um we we lived at my uh Aunt
dodo's house she was my great aunt um
she's a two-bedroom apartment with like
I think six people living there uh at
one
point and um my mom you know she she
struggled a lot as as I said and um she
she was going to massage therapy school
instead of going to um uh film school
she ended up deciding to go to massage
therapy school I think cuz it was a
safer uh bet you know and um it was a
little bit easier having children and
stuff um and she started working at a
restaurant called
bosos So eventually we got um a studio
apartment was my mom my brother and I
and we lived there and um my mom
finished massage school and uh uh
started doing massage professionally um
on top of still working at the
restaurant then we got a two-bedroom
apartment which was is really cool um
you know kind of slowly building and um
yeah my mom was really artistic and into
music uh I I can remember when we were
kids we'd wake up every morning and
she'd be playing a record and she'd play
that record for a week so the ones that
stick out for me are Rattle and hum by
you two uh that first solo record Steve
Perry put out with the that song O
Sherry uh she did hooting the lfish for
a week uh and so yeah and she had very
eclectic taste it'd beat you know the
doors and Lead Zeppelin but then it'd
also be you know like I said hoodie and
uh Our Lady Peace or Third Eye
Blind and uh so I got into music myself
pretty young and my mom bought me my
first guitar it was um a PV Raptor
Series 3 and it was like
$150 for the amp and the guitar and like
a little gig bag and a book and some
pics and it wasn't a very like nice
guitar it was you know it was cheap but
uh it was what my mom could afford and
it was all I needed so I guess yeah
that's what our life consisted of just
like uh trying to make it um you know
doing what we could and um yeah we we
uh my mom was my mom was um she was
really sad a lot of the time when I was
a kid I didn't realize it then uh but
you know looking back now I I can
remember so many uh nights where my mom
would just be crying and and you know
when you're a kid you don't really know
what's going on I guess I just assumed
that something had happened that day or
she just you know but I think it was it
was probably had a lot to do with my dad
and her feeling alone and lonely and uh
raising my brother and I and not knowing
what to do
and um
she uh yeah she she cried an awful lot
when we were kids and used to freak out
um she also drank a lot too and um it
was kind of it was scary for us
because uh she would she would pass out
like in the middle of the the living
room um you know there was a quite a few
times for my brother and I thought she
was dead cuz she wouldn't she wouldn't
get up and you know she would urinate on
herself it was really it was super scary
so yeah just um it was a little bit
hectic there was a lot of chaos there
was always chaos going on she she did
the best she could but
she she wasn't really
uh she wasn't uh she I I don't know I
guess she could have done a lot better
it's it's strange to say because now she
takes care of my son she has custody of
him she does really great with him but
at that time yeah she I don't know um
there's some resentments I have like I
always kind of want to ask her like why
why is it you you do so good with my kid
now but you couldn't do you know this
with my brother and I but you know
hindsight so anyway uh we so we grew up
in LA and your grandson will say that to
you what's that your grandson will say
that to you yeah well yeah and and I've
heard that but it's just
like
my we we moved we moved to uh Texas and
we w W there very long and my mom's uh
high school sweetheart came down and i'
never really met the guy his name was
Mark um and he asked my mom to marry him
and it was just like you know who is
this guy you know and everything just
kind of changed so we we went from
California to Texas to
Michigan and uh I mean I guess it took
us by surprise but the whole like moving
around thing we were used to that and uh
we were sort of used to not knowing what
what could happen next or what was going
to what was going to happen tomorrow and
Etc so anyway we we moved in with him
and he ended up being really really
abusive and I I have to say my mother
was abusive too especially when she
drank uh but this guy made her look like
Mother Teresa you know like he was um he
was
just yeah next level he was verbally
physically emotionally just completely
and totally abusive um he was uh always
accusing my mom of cheating like it was
insane it was wild he was um super
paranoid and like really good at math he
like he was a highly intelligent guy so
he'd do things like he'd be like uh my
mom would pick us up from school and
we'd get back and go where were you and
she'd be like picking the kids up and
he'd be like it takes 17 uh minutes and
33 seconds exactly with traffic and
without it it's 14 point you know
whatever seconds and you've been gone
for 21 minutes so that means you had
enough time to stop and suck somebody's
dick like like he would say stuff like
that it was it was wild and then he'd
look at us and he'd interrogate us where
was she what was she doing did you wait
in the car like you know and if we
didn't answer the way he wanted you know
we'd get punished for it uh super driven
guy too like we had to have all A's and
B's uh otherwise you know was an ass
whooping and we were grounded for a very
very long time and we couldn't do
anything like um we got to read books
that he picked for us that was it um and
my brother got it the worst
because he um he folded Under Pressure
like yeah he just he was always so
stressed out and so anxious I remember
one time we were in the the kitchen and
we had to present our report cards every
time we got a report card we had to give
it to him my brother's sitting there and
he's just like he's shaking because he's
so afraid of what's going to happen for
whatever reason my stepdad was in a good
mood that day so he looked at his report
he goes wow two FS he goes I guess
you'll have to do better next time and
he puts it down he goes all right I'll
see you guys I'm going to work and my
brother as soon as he walked out the
door he started crying like he wept and
I go what's wrong you're not in trouble
and he goes I just I don't know I don't
know why I'm crying like
I'm like
uh I guess I'm just overwhelmed I
thought I was going to get in trouble
and it's
weird you know looking back on all that
now cuz I felt so powerless at the time
you know cuz I couldn't help my mom or
my brother but um I used to stick it to
him by uh beating his expectation so if
it's all a and Beast then I wanted to
have all a like when I graduated high
school I had basically a 4.0 um I had a
c in math but I had all A's and
everything else I had a 3.9 but yeah I
just I always wanted to beat him so that
was like how I operated he he like
instilled this drive and this anger and
this bitterness to me and it just it it
made me want to beat him so um he also
taught me how to play guitar and that
was another goal of mine I wanted to be
better than him at Guitar um and he
introduced me to the band Le Zeppelin
which are my favorite band and I wanted
to be able to play every song by Leed
Zeppelin just so I could show him and
because there was a lot of songs by Leed
Zeppelin he couldn't play
so um yeah but a lot of chaos still the
chaos you know kind of stuck with us and
um that their marriage didn't last very
long it was like a year and a half and
um they got a really nasty
divorce
and uh during this time right before the
divorce I had gotten um injured I had
hurt at my back i' had gotten a
herniated disc in my
back uh and when they got divorced um I
I was given a prescription for pain
Killers it started off I think it was
narcos but eventually I was taking
oxycodone doctor was giving me and I
didn't realize you know at the time what
was going to happen but um yeah the the
uh the divorce started happening and he
cut everything off no more you know my
mom's cards were canceled we had nowhere
to go we were we were literally homeless
we were sleeping in public places uh my
mom worked at the salon we had to sleep
there a couple times
um yeah he he made it so we had nothing
and nowhere to go so while while that's
happening um the insurance that we were
all under um got cut off too like we
were no longer on his insurance and this
one day I was at a friend's house and I
started getting I started feeling just
crazy sick like like I had this really
intense flu but I'll never forget I had
this really bad anxiety too I couldn't
explain it my leg was was was shaking a
lot uh and I happened to be at a
friend's house his name was well I
probably shouldn't say his name uh his
first name was Mike and he noticed that
I was sick and I go what's wrong with me
like I feel so strange you know and I I
was like having a panic attack he goes
uh dude you're dope sick and I go that's
not impossible I don't I don't do dope I
don't do drugs and he goes you take
those pills though right I go yeah he
goes what are they I go oxy C he goes
yeah that's hillbilly heroin that's
that's what that is and I go it's really
and he goes yeah so I looked at him and
I go what am I supposed to do like my my
stepdad cut the insurance off we can't
go to the doctor or anything anymore and
he goes I know somebody that can help
you out but it's not going to be with
pills and it's not something I recommend
and I said what is it he goes uh he's
he's got heroin and uh he goes it's
basically the same thing um it's just
you know there's no acetam inan so it's
probably better for your liver and
stomach and I was so sick and delusional
at the time I
said well that makes sense and it's
going to make me feel better right he
goes yeah I said okay uh I guess give
him a call so he comes over this guy Dan
and um I said well how much will 10
bucks give me he goes this much and he
says you only need a little uh so just
try to you know ration it out uh until
you get more money so I I snorted a
little line of uh China White heroin for
the first time and I you know a couple
minutes later I got really really high
and um I remember I felt a hundred times
better and in fact even better than
before and uh I'll never forget I said
out loud I'm in big trouble I knew right
then and there that I loved this feeling
and I was going to chase after it for
the rest of my life I always equate it
to this this might sound a little
strange but uh like like your first
orgasm like um that that very first one
uh or the first time you fall in love
with somebody it's just an incredible
intense feeling that's
Indescribable and you you just you don't
know where exactly it's coming from you
just know you want to have it over and
over and over you never want it to
stop and uh so I started buying heroin
and um while all this is going on I'm
also still playing guitar and um now I'm
learning new instruments too and uh my
step father as I said you know did uh
and my mom both shared really really
great uh music with me and allowed me to
like I don't know really really explore
my musical inclination I guess and my
talents and they were supportive and
encouraging of that
so I graduated high school 3 years early
uh graduated when I was 15 I got bumped
up a few grades and after that I just
stayed home uh yeah doing heroin
drinking booze and practicing guitar and
um I started I I started working at a
skate park to and everybody there was uh
getting high because everybody was
always getting injured and so everybody
was always like you know they had a
prescription and uh this was in the
early 2000s so uh this is before you
know the DEA started cracking down on
everything and big Pharma you know they
they weren't in trouble yet I guess is a
good way to put it so uh a lot of my
good friends yeah they had Naros they
had per cetes they had oxycodone some of
them had oxycotton and all of them were
prescribed by a doctor and um so like I
was still buying the heroin but I was
also taking pills that my friends would
give me and
um yeah it just it was it was insane and
and we uh none of us kind of viewed each
other as having a problem like you know
we we always used to say oh we could
stop at any time time uh I would say
that to people but I was lying to them
and to myself I knew I couldn't stop
like at the very least I didn't want to
like it was it something uh would have
to make me want to stop something really
bad and at the time you know and and I
was like there's nothing bad that could
come of this like you know I just got to
be
careful so um we uh we we were in
Michigan for a couple more years and
then my mom just was like you know all I
have is bad memories here I think we
should go back to Texas
and so we went back to Texas and
um I got married when I was uh uh
18 and
I my marriage was awful it was super
toxic really volatile and uh I uh had
been off the pills for a little while in
the heroin because we moved from
Michigan to Texas and I couldn't get a
hold of um you know anything and but
eventually I started working at this
hotel and there was this guy there that
uh was prescribed morphine and narcos
and uh I noticed his prescription
bottles one day and I just kind of asked
him about it I go do you take these
regularly no not really he goes every
now and again he goes but um it's for my
back and uh yeah like I I just bring him
whenever I know it's going to be a long
day at work cuz we were valet drivers so
there's a lot of running and walking I
go well could I have a couple of them
and goes yeah sure how many do you want
I go I don't know as many as you want to
give so we G he gives me five that day
I'll never forget he gave me morphine
sulfate
pills
and it was an incredible feeling there's
different highs so like you have the
fentanyl High you've got the you know
your your sub high is like Suboxone
Subutex you've got your heroin High
you've got your painkiller High they're
all different morphine was probably one
of the better ones so
uh every time he'd come to work I
started I would ask him for something
like I don't know man like eventually go
he goes I don't know I'm running kind of
alone I go I'll buy them from you for a
good price and he goes well what's a
good price and I go well how much do you
get the prescription for and he goes
well I have insurance so like eight
bucks or something and I go well I'll
give you five bucks a pill so you know I
it's a pretty high profit margin he goes
wow he goes and I get like 30 of those
every month plus my wife gets them too
because she had a tumor in her back uh
and she hardly takes them too and I go
yeah I mean if you want I'll buy them
all from you and he go $5 a pill yeah
hell yeah uh so I started buying them
from him and
um uh oh my my wife and I at the time we
opened up a clothing store and then I
opened a recording studio with uh the
producer of The Strokes Gordon
Raphael and so I started um I was living
in San Antonio at the time and and I
sort of gained this notoriety and um
people started to kind of you know ask
about me and figure out who I was I was
becoming popular I guess or locally I
was becoming famous because you know The
Strokes had just W album of the decade
by enemy and second best album of the
decade with rolling stone and Gordon was
the um you know the guy that produced a
record that won
so uh now I'm having parties at my place
and I'm I'm throwing fashion shows at my
clothing store and uh I'm meeting people
that are you know like-minded and now
I'm starting to find uh heroin
connections and other pangular
connections and I'm starting to spiral a
little bit my marriage is getting worse
and worse and we're lying to everybody
and saying that everything's great but
uh It
Wasn't
So eventually uh I start partying way
too hard
and I I just my marriage was so bad that
I I you know resigned myself to the fact
that it was over and then my ex-wife
cheated on me with my best friend
several times and that was just that was
it so I
uh I kicked her out
because
um I I should mention too we had his son
we had a child together but I kicked her
out because I was the one that had
bought the clothing store I bought the
um um the recording studio for the most
part I was taking care of uh our son uh
not not as responsibly as I should have
but I mean he was usually with me and
one of the our biggest fights was she
was always going out and not telling me
where she was going and she'd come home
at crazy random odd hours and uh then
when I found out she was cheating and uh
all that sort of thing I just yeah I had
had enough and so I told her she had to
go and
um I got really depressed because even
though I had asked her to leave um you
know I still loved her and I missed her
so uh I started partying harder and now
I'm partying alone I'm not even partying
anymore it's not a party it's just me in
a room doing drugs you know doing
morphine and heroin and Cocaine by
myself while my son's asleep in the Next
Room and um then she she had asked to
visit with him she has to see him and I
told her I had to think about it just
cuz I didn't trust her and
so yeah she she did eventually see and
of course she kidnapped him she uh took
off with him and this became a regular
thing she would um she would kind of win
her way back into my heart and I I
didn't want to get back together with
her but I wanted her to see the you know
our kids so I'd be like okay well
someone's got to stay with her at all
times and and no matter what just don't
take your eyes off her and somehow she
she was slick she would sneak by she
jumped out of window one time like she
actually jumped out of window with him
and took off and I didn't see him for
like a whole year
so um yeah it's like a regular thing
it's just her pattern and I would get so
depressed and so upset that I would you
know continue to take opiates and
continue to build the tolerance and
continue to use uh opiates to cope
and
um
So eventually though I met
um this girl called Julia Julia Bryant
and she's like my best friend but her
and I met and we fell in love and we
started dating and she we were so I
guess I I was young and we were so into
each other that she she got me to quit
taking drugs like she was just like you
know I really like you and I think
you're a great guy and it would be
really shitty if uh if you weren't here
anymore if something happened to you
like and it sounds like when you don't
take this stuff you get really sick and
that's usually not not a good sign and I
was so under at the time and and kind of
started to thinking I was like yeah I I
do need to get my son back too like I
haven't seen my son and God only knows
how long and I've neglected looking for
him I should be out looking for him
more so I I got off the drugs and
eventually they did find him and he came
back and he came and stayed with me
again and
um
we things were good for a while and uh
his mom would asked to see him and I'd
be like nope no way no no
no and
uh
So eventually Julia and I broke up
though and it was it was really really
hard was like so much harder than um my
like marriage ending like I was
completely and totally hopelessly in
love with Julia and the reason we broke
up was because I was drinking way too
much and and you know causing a scene
every time we went out and did something
something and so when we broke up what
did I do I went right back to doing
drugs and then this one time uh my son's
mother calls me and she's she's crying
and I guess her and her boyfriend at the
time had got into a fight and he had uh
beat her up
and
uh I I felt bad and I I didn't you know
I didn't have any romantic feelings for
her but I did feel bad and I said okay
listen how can I help and she said can I
just stay with you I don't have anywhere
to go and I said listen you can stay but
it's only going to be for a couple days
and if you do anything to screw me over
like I swear to God you'll never see him
again like as as long as I live and as
long as I'm able to fight this you you
won't see him again so she comes and she
stays with me and she gets really
comfortable and she starts talking about
wanting to stay there and us working
things out and I said no no no no I'm
not working anything out like I
understand you're in a tough spot and
I'm willing to like let you stay here a
little longer but you can't yeah we're
not going to talk about us getting back
together I guess she took that a little
bit personal and wasn't really happy
about it and then I went and um I asked
her if she'd watch
him uh one night and I went off with
some girl and she knew about it and that
also upset her so a couple days later we
um we're
we're arguing and she starts drinking
and she's just acting you know insane
and I go to sleep we have a big argument
and I go to sleep and I wake up and of
course they're gone so I was super
pissed and uh I just thought here we go
again and you know what do I do I start
using drugs
again and
uh
eventually uh I meet somebody else and
uh her name was Ella and Ella was the uh
person that really really helped me get
it together with regard to like uh my
son and my legal situation with him and
uh everything else like she was a big-
time music lover herself she like the
exact same music I did the same bands um
big Strokes fan big Leed Zeppelin fan um
you know just just yeah all around Great
Taste of music and she was working at
Alliance Bernstein which is like a a a
very big um financial
institution and um she was making really
good money but she'd told me she'd be
like I I wish I could have a in music
and I'd be like well why can't you I
mean I'm a musician um and she goes yeah
but it's so competitive and you don't
make very much money and blah blah blah
and I go that's not true at all I go if
you're working behind the scenes and you
know what you're doing you can make a
lot of money it's harder for me as a
musician and there's more competition in
that respect but like all you really do
need to do is go to school and you know
get a degree and then an internship or
just start at the bottom somewhere you
know start as a as a receptionist at a
record label take that picture up for a
little while so I start planting these
seeds in her mind and she eventually
quit Alliance Bernstein and decided to
help me full-time with my
um with my music career uh while working
like freelance for a Mara Lynch uh from
the
house so all that's happening and I get
a call one day uh from Child Protective
Services and they said they've located
uh my son uh he had almost died and he
was in the hospital he was being treated
for dehydration and malnutrition and all
this other stuff and they said that uh
when they found him he was passed out um
and you know in U di I think it's
diabetic uh ketosis um basically he's he
has Type 1 diabetes and he's autistic so
he he has hard time a hard time
communicating so he couldn't tell his
mother that you know he was hungry but
she wasn't feeding him anyway and and by
this time she had had two kids with two
other guys uh as well and then she'd
also run off with them like the cops
were looking for her for like three
different you know child endangerment uh
charges
so uh they find them in an abandoned
warehouse her two daughters and and my
son uh and she I guess was slump passed
out with a needle in her arm and my son
yeah was underfed
uh you know dehydrated as I said and was
not in a good way so CPS asked if they
can come over to my house and see that
make sure that it's a safe environment
and I guess after seeing uh her in the
way she was living they just assume that
she was probably that I was probably
someone kind of like her but they came
over and the CPS investigator was
shocked she was like wow like she's like
I'm going to be honest I didn't expect
you know it to be like this here you
know because a lot of times couples
you know uh birds of a feather flock
together and I go oh yeah no we're we're
not together anymore because yeah I'm
nothing like her and so yeah so he comes
and stays uh or comes to live with us
and now I feel like I've got you know
the world is my orer everything is great
my my music career is um starting to to
Blossom and everything's going well and
I have my son and uh my girl at the time
and we were we making things happen
and uh I was on probation at the
time and I ended up getting in trouble
while on probation which is a big no no
and so I got locked up for the first
time in sent to what's called an
intermediate sanction facility and I had
to get locked up for six months
basically you go to prison like a state
a state prison for six months and it's
it's just their way of punishing you and
and showing you like okay so if you
screw up this is what will happen for
years if you do it again one of those
things Texas has um they have ISF which
is the intermediate sanction facility
they have uh safe P which is substance
uh uh safe p is substance abuse felony
punishment and that's uh like a
nine-month program same
thing um and then they
have smart recovery which is
self-management and Recovery
training and then they have state jail
and then they have state prison and then
they have Federal there's all kind it's
crazy Texas is a very like prison for
profit private you know
uh we have to have a bunch of prison
type places and so that was my first
experience there and I remember being
there and I got to play guitar in the um
Church band and I started writing songs
and um I just felt so motivated I was
like wow like you know I could have
really screwed my life up and and gone
away for you know much longer and and uh
I got to take advantage of this time so
I started writing songs and I started
getting really serious with it um and so
I get out and I tell Ella like it's this
is this is it it's now or never like we
got to make this happen so I get the
band back together and I I I present
them with a bunch of songs that I had
written and uh the way it worked with my
band was I basically wrote all the songs
and they just you know played everything
that I wrote um kind of a perfectionist
that way so we uh at I would even go as
far as like when we would be recording
the only person that really got to play
in the recording studio was the drummer
CU I'm not a drummer but I played all
the instruments too it was just such a
control freak about everything so I go I
get out and I make a record and um uh a
friend of mine uh Anthony Bron Perry who
who's the basis for The Growlers helped
produce
it and um basically I slipped back into
using heroin i' had been clean for quite
a while because I'd been locked up and
um you can get drugs when you're locked
up but it's more expensive so it at the
time it just wasn't worth the hassle but
um so I get
uh this momentum and I'm I'm really
really working hard and I eventually get
some to a record label based out of LA
right here in La it's called pop
cautious
records and we do a showcase at the
hotel Cafe
downtown and we're getting shout outs
and we're getting interviews and we're
you
know doing the whole thing and then we
start touring and Anthony helps finish
the record and it's just a very very
very exciting time and uh uh I start I
start letting the uh the heroin kind of
take over again and now I'm I'm with the
friend and I'm doing cocaine and he's
like why do you do Coke he's like why
don't you do meth like it's literally
five times better three times cheaper
and last like you know twice as long or
you know like 20 times long my bad 20
times long and I said well I never
really thought about that I always just
kind of figured that was a gutter drug
and he goes no man just try it so I
tried meth for the first time
and at first it made me feel really
really
productive but eventually I start
building a tolerance kind of and now I'm
doing too much and I'm starting to spin
out of control and get really really
weird and I start you know getting
paranoid and and having all these
theories
that um about everything like I'm just
theorizing and hypothesizing all these
things and like I think everybody's out
to get me and eventually the label comes
to me and they're like yeah so we're
pretty sure you have a drug problem it's
not it's not not the end of the world
but we want you to go to rehab and I say
no no way um you know and I think to
myself how dare these people like I'm an
asset to them you know like I have a
unique sound there's no one on their
label like me like there's no uh band
that they have that sounds anything like
me like I'm a commodity I'm a valuable
commodity to them and that you know they
couldn't go on without me if they tried
and the reality was they uh they could
go on without me and and they did and
they you know did just fine uh but
um I at the like they started talking
about suspending my contract and uh I
said you know what I'll just I'll just
leave like you don't have to do any of
that so it was kind of like it wasn't
mutual and they were going to fire me
anyway but so I got really really really
depressed and acted like I didn't care
and I was like I still have plenty of
connections like I'll get signed one way
or the other to another label um but I
had a contract with him and it was just
in limbo like now it was it was all
screwed up and I I didn't really know
what I was going to do so I start doing
more meth you know and I'm still doing
heroin and the meth is just making me
insane and
um Ella starts to to she starts
to she's she's getting to the point
where she can't take my behavior anymore
either until one day she finally just
calls me and says you know I moved all
my things like while I was gone one day
she basically moved all her stuff out
and like just decided like she had had
enough so she was going back to Mexico
that's where she was from was Mexico
so um I got really sad and and down and
you know it's just like the year before
I had everything I wanted my son and
this this record deal and you know this
really nice place that I was living in
and several cars and all this music
equipment and gear and studio time and
now like I just have my place and my car
and my kid but I don't have a record
deal and I don't have anybody to share
share any of my stuff
with and
uh yeah so I start doing more and more
drugs and eventually I I lose I I
neglect everything I I don't pay any of
the bills I don't I don't work I don't
do any of that
you know I'm
so you know just deluded that I I I
don't know I I think that something's
going to happen and I don't need to do
anything I don't need to prepare for
anything and you know I have enough
money save that I'll be okay but I
didn't and so now I'm evicted and I have
my
son and um I start doing you know
hanging out with some really sketchy
people and eventually I become a
full-fledged criminal and I'm doing
illegal [__] like all the time to get
money for drugs and to to you know have
a place to
stay and uh I remember when I was when I
was a kid I I made two promises to
myself uh if I had kids I wasn't going
to end up like my father or end up like
my mother my father and that I was
always going to be around for my kid I
was never going to leave him or abandon
him and I wasn't going to be like my mom
in that um
I I wasn't going to let drugs or alcohol
like you know cloud my mind or my
judgment or or take you know precedence
over our relationship you know he was
always going to come
first but uh yeah it eventually got to
beware that was not the case so I'm
doing drugs with my son in the room uh
with me and I'm taking him on drug deals
and I'm taking him to these like
gangsters like these people that are
gangsters their house gang bangers the
whole thing I remember one time there
was a guy he thought I had stolen a
checkbook from him that was not even his
checkbook he was using it and cashing
someone else's checks and my son was
right in the Next Room asleep and he put
a gun to my
head and I just looked at him and I go
just do it man like just kill me like
You' just be doing me a favor like look
my son's in the Next Room sleeping uh
I'm neglecting him I know that I've got
nothing I don't have an apartment
anymore I don't have girlfriend I don't
have this I don't have that like I'm a
junkie like if you pull that trigger
you'd just be doing me a favor um it
would suck for you too because you'd
have to hide the body and I don't know
if you have it in you to kill children I
don't think so um but I would hope that
you wouldn't hurt my kid and um he just
kind of looks at me and he goes you're
[__] crazy man and uh he goes I want
that checkbook back and I go I you know
I don't I don't have it but that's like
what my my days consisted of now like
people coming over and trying to rob me
or robbing me uh one one time not too
long after that I um I I was staying in
a Motel
6 and I called my drug dealer and
apparently he was in some hot water with
like the cartel and that's because
that's who he was getting it
from and he just so happened to have a
cousin that was in the cartel like
normally they wouldn't you know he was
he was buying like I
think like he he he wasn't buying he was
getting a brick fronted to him and um he
was selling you know ounces and stuff
and he was selling to me
because uh he was he was trying to build
a rapport I guess because eventually
what happened was he snuck into my hotel
room when he found out I was in a
vulnerable spot and uh he he clocked me
in the back of the head with the Baton
and knocked me out unconscious gave me a
really bad concussion and stole all the
gear that I had everything I had from
being a musician my Moog Voyager my
guitars my amps uh my yeah my mixing
console like I had a bunch of stuff uh I
had stuff to make music videos too
drones cameras um green screens lights
and um yeah he knocked me out cold right
in front of my
son and took all my stuff and when I
came to and woke
up my my son was sitting in there crying
and I'm sure he
was you know very confused and
scared and I I'll never forget the
headache I had it was so bad it was like
someone was pounding on the side of my
head with a bowling ball you know just
hitting me in the side of the head so um
I freaked out and I was so screwed up
from getting hit that number one I
didn't even know it was him at the time
my own drug dealer I call him right
after I come back to and I was like hey
can you come drop something off to me
man like I I just got robbed and I don't
even know who did it and you know blah
blah blah and he's like yeah yeah yeah
I'll be right there and uh he calls me
when he gets to the hotel though and
he's like there's nothing funny going
on now is there like what do you mean he
goes like I'm not walking into anything
right and I go what are you talking
about man and I didn't know but he was
now paranoid because he just robbed me
and he's trying to figure out if I'm you
know hip to him and I wasn't and I go
like now I'm taking it back and I I
don't understand what the question is
about but I go dude I just I just need
some dope you know and so
he he sells it to me and then a couple
hours later I found out that it was him
that robbed me and uh it was him that
put my my son in that dangerous
situation and the same people who tell
me are like hey you know we we'll look
after you we'll take care of you we'll
help you out whatever whatever um but
you got to you got to take your kid to
your mom or something like he can't be
coming around here cuz we're all doing
drugs we're partying and we don't don't
we don't want any part of that you know
having the kid around and
so I
uh I didn't want to admit it at the time
but I I I did give my I asked my mom if
she would watch my son for a little
while just a couple weeks cuz I was
going to start working at some place and
I needed time to just focus and by this
time my mom knew that I had a really bad
drug problem and um she she was happy to
take him just cuz she thought it was
good for for me
to you know get away from him for a
little bit maybe get myself right and if
I didn't get myself right then you know
at least he was in a safe place and he
was healthy
and you know not around a bunch of drug
dealers and drug users so uh what ended
up happening though was they the reason
why they um they they wanted
me without him was I was getting his
disability checks every month on a debit
card and I somehow screwed up and told
them about it and I was getting like
1,200
bucks so they have him they like I they
helped me take him to my mom and I drop
them off with my mom and they wait for
the first of the month and at first they
tried to like you
know I guess manipulate me into giving
them money and then they tried to
Strongarm me and they're like you know
you've been staying with us blah blah
blah and I'm like yeah but you know I've
been helping you guys with a lot of
stuff too and they're like yeah well
it's done enough and I how's it not
enough I'm doing the same amount of work
as you know so and so and they're like
it's not enough cuz we say it's not
enough and they were basically setting
me up so that they could take that money
but also they wanted me to cash a bunch
of fraudulent checks and use a bunch of
stolen credit cards they were going to
make me the guinea pig or the crash
dummy whatever you want to call
it
and
um it it all like it finally you know
crashed down on me and and they they we
got into sort of an argument and they
beat me up and they tied me to a chair
and they started hitting me in the in
the face and asking me for the pin of uh
my kid's uh you know debit card and I
didn't break I said listen I'm not
giving you the card you can sit here and
beat me as much as you want but I'm not
giving you the PIN to that to that card
but if you untie me I will go to the
bank and I'll pull the money out and you
can have the money and so they took that
deal and then I came back and they tied
me up again they're like you're going to
cash some checks tomorrow and I was like
fine
whatever and uh I'm sitting there and I
start crying and they're like why are
you crying and I'm like cuz I got rid of
my kid like I I sent him over to my mom
um because he was an inconvenience to my
high and because you guys asked me to
and I would rather impress you guys and
be hanging out with you and doing drugs
than I I you know then to be hanging out
with him and that's the kind of person I
am now and that's just really
unfortunate
so you know they didn't want to hear
that they told me to shut up and um they
eventually fell asleep and what I did
was I was able to slip out of the the
situation they had me tied up with and I
just snuck out of the room and took off
and uh went to I went back to Austin I
was living in San Antonio at this time
um I had moved from Austin to San
Antonio now I go back to
Austin and um
eventually
I get uh some money because my son's
disability check comes in and I call my
mom and um I'm like I want to see Cass
and so she brings him to me and I go
okay he's going to stay with me and
she's like begging me you know let let
him just stay with me like I can take
care of him for a while like you're
obviously going through a hard time
right now whatever whatever and I said
no I'm fine like everything's okay now
like I'm going to be okay and
um you know he's he's just a little boy
at this time he's you know s years old8
years old and he um he's got the
diabetes as I said and it's now worse
than it was before where I'm going to
drug dealers houses and they're stealing
his needles because he has to get the
insulin injections and you know getting
clean needles for a lot of these guys is
kind of a task
So eventually I mean we're sleeping on
couches he's he's getting sick he's
just and we're moving around all these
places and I'm putting him
through like just
these I'm putting him through you know
these things that he doesn't deserve
like he's I'm not feeding him every
every day the way I'm supposed to be
feeding him like I'm
not he's supposed to eat three times a
day and he's supposed to get you know
insulin shots and I'm not even giving
him insulin when he's supposed to to get
insulin and I'm forgetting and I'm
passing out and falling asleep and
just you know not worrying about him I'm
just kind of worrying about myself and
um he's still like every time I wake up
though he's he gets really excited to
see me
like I'm not even taking care of him you
know I'm just kind
of I'm neglecting that's what I'm
doing and every time I wake up though he
he always looks at me goes dad you're
awake I missed
you and
um yeah so this this one day he
um he
uh I take him to a you know like a drug
house a trap house and he
um he's sitting there waiting on go just
wait here we're in the living room and
um I go and I buy heroin and meth from
somebody and I come back out and
somebody had stolen all his needles his
insulin needles and um I didn't have any
money I just spent it all on the
drugs and so I say to myself I could
um get give some of this this dope back
cuz obviously I'm not going to get these
needles back but I could give some of
this dope back and go uh get new
needles but you know what I'm going to
do instead because I don't want to give
some of this DP back is I'm going to
just go beg the pharmacy to get me some
of the
needles which you know looking back down
it's like I'm a junkie and I'm shooting
dope and they're going to look at me and
go yeah okay sure it's for him and you
know I had the um prescription to prove
it and everything but
yeah I just they so stupid but we didn't
have a ride I had used all my money so
we have no ride and now he starts
getting sick and he's going into
diabetic kosis again and he's getting
really sick and now he's um he's he's
puking all over himself and he's peeing
on himself and he can't move and he just
looks really really sick and he keeps
staring at me with this look like
um you know am I going to feel better
soon like and he keeps looking to me
like like I'm supposed to help him like
I'm supposed to protect him because I
was and
um he just looked so sad like he was so
confused and um it's like a whole day I
I left
him hanging for a whole day just sick
really really sick because I I I
couldn't figure out a way to get to the
hospital and I couldn't figure out a way
to get to the pharmacy
and I was
I was just busy getting high was what it
really was and
um
uh he um he gets so bad that eventually
I have to call an ambulance so I go I
don't remember it was some random
neighborhood and I I call an ambulance
and they they get there and they're kind
of looking at me and I'm in the the the
back of the truck with him and
um he just looks really sad and really
scared and they're looking at me and
they're like what's going on I'm like I
don't know his we lost these needles and
I couldn't find a ride and you know
we're we're homeless right now
and I just yeah I don't know what to do
and I say I'm a good father I mean I
want to be a good father and they're
like we're not judging we just you know
and um we get to the hospital and one of
the paramedics um gives me a uh a little
lot of cash and I think there was like
40 bucks there
so yeah um it was it was a pretty
pathetic
site and we get upstairs to the room and
he just looks he he looks like he was
dead like he was lifeless and he's all
hooked up to different IVs and stuff and
the doctor comes to me and she said he's
in he's in um uh something what was it
called um anyway she said he's he's near
death like he's it's we have to turn
this around he's like in critical
condition right now um so they take him
to the ICU and he looks really sad and
he's trying to hold my hand while I'm
sitting next to his hospital bed and um
it's hurting his hand cuz he's got a an
IV in
it um so he takes his other hand and
puts it on my hand and he just look
really really really sad and um I fell
asleep and I wake up up
and there's a guy there and he says he's
with CPS he's a CPS investigator and he
said that while I had fallen asleep I
was knocked out for hours they couldn't
get me up which you know I was smoking
meth for like a week and not sleeping so
that's what that was and
um they they went through my bag while I
was um asleep and they found paraphernal
and other stuff too so they kicked me
out of the hospital and I go outside and
my mom's um my mom's best friend is
there and she's like you know he's going
to be okay you know your mom's just
going to look after him for a while go
get help go get help like everything
everything is going to be okay like you
just got to go get help
and
um yeah so the first thing I do is I go
to my drug dealer's house instead of
going to get help I go to my drug
dealer's house and um I explain to them
what's going on I said I'm depressed can
you just help me out cuz I don't really
have much right now and
um they uh they weren't that sympathetic
to it they gave me something
but yeah um I realized like in that
moment like the one person who really
really really cared about me and would
do anything for me uh and who who held
me up
high you know my real friend I just
abandoned and neglected and left alone
and you know for these people that
are you know don't care about me and
just want my money
and um
so I uh I start getting into legal
trouble
like the worst at like the worst
possible way and um I'm picking up
charges and cases now that are
like they make all my old um cases from
when I was uh um in my late teens and
early 20s they like they make me look
like a saint and uh yeah like I'm I'm
getting robbery I'm getting burglary I'm
getting uh possession charges I'm
getting uh unlawful carry of a weapon by
a felon um I'm getting theft of mail I'm
getting uh credit card abuse I'm
getting this and that and uh I even got
caught sneaking drugs into a jail one
time and and they charged me with a
uh prohibited uh Contraband and
substance in a Correctional Complex and
that was a state jail felony but
um
so yeah I'm going to jail and I'm
getting locked up a
bunch and um I keep thinking about my
son but like I'm like you know I'm just
I'm he's better off without me So
eventually
um the the CPS lawyer that was
representing me comes and he said you
know what do you want to do and I said I
want you to give me the paperwork and I
want to sign over custody of my son to
my mom and he goes are you sure because
if if you get you know we can get you
out of jail once you're out like we can
we can appeal this and we can beat this
and we can fight this and we can do this
and that
and uh you'll you'll get custody you
just got to go into treatment and you
got to get help
and I
uh I didn't want to do that I was like
no he's just he's better he's better off
with my mom and the truth is like he
wasn't better off with my mom and I
could have done the right thing um but
he was an inconvenience to my high like
that's the truth like I was so badly
addicted and so swallowed whole by my
addiction and my love for OPI it's that
I
am I abandoned my my son
because
um I I would just rather get high than
deal with anything too heavy or you know
something like that
so um so I signed over custody and then
eventually of course I got out of jail
and um I just went nuts went really
really really nuts
finally um I start I get into a position
where I'm looking at really serious
prison time and
um I get I get
the a new charge while on probation and
I'm looking at six years now and they're
like yeah you uh it's going to take some
convincing on um hour Parts my lawyer
tells me um you know you're going to
have to convince the judge because this
is bad and she said would you go to
rehab and I finally kind of look and I
said yeah I guess so i' had been so
against rehab for so long and I I just
kind of was like well maybe I
should consider rehab now maybe it is
time to get clean because of all the
stuff that's happening and at the time I
mean I was just I was still being so
selfish like the only reason I would go
to rehab was because I didn't want to go
uh back to prison and I didn't uh I mean
you know once I was done with rehab
anyway I could get out and uh go back to
doing drugs so
I go to one of those State mandated
facilities uh that I mentioned before
smart and it's basically like a jail
complex it's like it's like prison but
it's it's you know they make you do
programs all day but it's run just like
a prison you know you're in a uniform
and yeah I mean that's exactly what it
looks like it's like a little mini
prison with a just yeah drug counselors
there all day so um I do that and
I I
complete um the program and my brother
who had been in and out of rehab um had
um called me and said that he was clean
and he had said that I could go stay
with him while I you know was trying to
get back on my feet
and he said you know I'm really trying
to to keep things kosher though at my
house so like please um
please you
know be respectful and I get out and I
relapsed within about a week I would say
and uh so as soon as I relapse I start
going heavy and hard in the paint and
like like I brought home six uh iMac
computers one day and I I'd gotten them
with a stolen credit card they're all
brand new in the box and um I come home
with a bunch of drugs and my brother
finds him and he gets really mad and
he's like you shouldn't be doing that BL
blah and um I kind of caught on though
and I knew my brother was using at the
time too so um I just said hey man like
who are you to say anything to me about
getting high around he he figured out
that I knew that he was getting high so
he didn't really say much after that
well um a few days later I go to the
apartment and he wouldn't give me a key
he did he did not want me to have a key
so I go to the apartment though at the
time I'm supposed to be there for
curfew and and he uh he had locked the
door and he wasn't home and so I call
and I call and I call and he's not
answering the
phone and he doesn't show up and I'm
sitting there waiting for hours and I
got so pissed I kicked the door
in and um yeah
like I was so mad that I kicked the door
and I tried to put it back on the hinges
but I was like whatever you know what he
left me outside it he got what he
deserved so he gets home and he's pissed
and he's like you know I can't have this
like you just you got to go and I said
you know like have what like what are
you talking about he's like dude you're
you're a loser like you don't have a job
you don't uh have any responsibilities
you don't have you know you don't even
have your son right now like what's the
matter with you and I said listen man I
may not have a job or any of the crap
you have but like at least I'm happy and
I love doing what I do like
I don't get to I don't have to answer to
anybody I get to do whatever I want and
we're getting to a really big fight and
it's about to come to blows and I put on
a pair of brass knuckles and he looks at
me like oh I don't want to get hit with
those and he goes just get out please
like leave my
house so I said you know what [__] you
[__] die and uh I grabed my stuff I
closed the door and that was the last
time I ever saw my brother alive
again and uh I didn't know it at the
time but um so I go out and I'm doing
what I do and I'm
stealing credit card information and
checks and I'm printing these checks and
you know doing identity theft and stuff
like that and I helped this one kid
Ryan uh his uh he's a heroin addict too
and he doesn't have any money and he ask
me if if he goes if I let you use my
account could you get a bunch of money
put in there and I said yeah absolutely
and so it's exactly what I did and we he
had spent like as soon as we made the
money he went and bought a bunch of
heroin and he gave it to his girlfriend
who then proceeded to break up with him
and leave and take off with the heroin
and he says hey I need some more money
and I said well I
mean you know it doesn't work like that
we got to have we have to have another
bank account this one's no good anymore
and you know he said we can't use mine
anymore I said no and
so um I've got $33,000
and he knows that and so we're driving
this this one time and uh after we've
discussed this it's like the next day
we're driving and um all of a sudden he
proceeds to punch me and it didn't
really the punch didn't
hurt but then like it kind of you know
caught me off guard so I I go to punch
him and then all of a sudden I I have
this sharp pain in my uh my arm and uh
he he'd stabbed me and was was stabbing
me repeatedly he stabbed me here and
then he starts going for my throat and
he got me in the neck he missed my
throat but I put my arm up I put my hand
up you probably can't see that he
stabbed me in the stomach he stabbed me
in the leg he stabbed me here he stabbed
me in the neck and he stabbed me in the
hand and he was going through the throat
though like I so I was going like this
and so when he finally got me in the
hand the knife got stuck and that was
when I you know pulled it back and
started punching him and I jumped out of
the car which by the way I was driving
so he could have killed us both and he
was very clearly trying to steal the
money from me so I jumped out of the
car and I take off running
and
um I uh somebody had seen what had
happened and they called the police so
the cops come to talk to me and they
asked me what's going on and I said I
don't know he just freaked out and went
crazy and he's like no no no [__]
this guy was trying to kidnap me and he
stole my money and I go H see I go no
that that's not true that's not true at
all and I go listen if you get into my
phone right now like Meanwhile by the
way like I'm I'm bleeding everywhere I'm
holding myself and I'm in so much pain
and I can barely talk but I was like if
you get into my phone right now and call
dial the last number that I called uh I
go just ask that woman where we're
supposed to meet her who all was uh
coming to meet her and uh you know how
much money we were taking with us and uh
I go that'll prove it right there she'll
say that he was with me or that I was
with him and we're showing up with you
know whatever and so the police call and
yeah sure enough she verifies so they
take him to
jail and I go and stay with another drug
dealer friend of mine and I run into
this guy
who is um salty about some debt he
thinks I owe him from a year or so
before so we get into an argument I said
you know look dude I just got stabbed
like I I can't deal with this right now
like um let's talk about it later please
and he's like okay okay I got you so we
um we I follow asleep and I'm in so much
pain and eventually I I get
up and uh he comes back into he comes
back over to the house and he comes into
the room where I'm staying that same
drug dealer and he said hey I have a way
we can we can make this debt you know we
can squash this debt and you can make
some money and I said okay what's up so
he says just come with me so I get in
the car and we pull up to this place and
he's like
um um just wait here like don't move
stay here okay and I go okay wasn't
planning on moving like uh and um he
leaves the car on and all of a sudden he
he gets on he's standing at the corner
he's acting very suspicious and then
this uh car pulls up behind me and it's
a bunch of Hispanic looking gentlemen
with guns and they get out and I go oh
crap like I think I know what this is
they're trying to kidnap me so I I jump
over into the driver's seat he had left
the keys in the car thank God and I took
off and they start shooting at me and
they they got me in the arm um I don't
think my jacket will go up that far but
they got me in the arm and so I'm
driving and I am I'm I'm now I'm
freaking out and I'm shot uh after
having just been stabbed you know like a
week or two prior or something like that
and
I I run or I I take off driving and I I
go to a hotel or a motel and I get out
and I explain the situation and they
called the police and the police thought
I was going crazy
and that like you know I don't know what
they thought but I was talking in
circles and I was super paranoid and
super messed up too so um they yeah they
proceed to take me to get a psyche V
after uh stitching me up and you know
fixing me up and all that kind of thing
so
um anyway a couple days goes by and I'm
standing in this trap house one day and
somebody walks in and he goes hey man
where have you
been uh everybody's been looking for you
and trying to get a hold of you and I
said had a crazy couple of weeks why and
like who's trying to look for me he goes
I got bad news um your your brother
passed away and I said what you know get
the [__] out of here and I go you don't
even know my brother he goes dude it's
all over your Facebook people are
looking for you your brother died and he
goes his name is Jonas right and I
go H you know and I'm just confused and
I'm like what do you mean like how did
he die and he goes I don't know
so
um uh I start thinking about it and I'm
like it must have been the dope and um
all of a sudden this feeling comes over
me like
um I remember the last thing that
I that I said to him was uh
[__] off and [__]
die and
um what really sucks is I had just
gotten out of treatment when I went to
stay with him like it wasn't like a
cushy luxury rehab but it was
a it was some sober time and it was me
digging into what the problem was and I
really did get into it so like I could
have
um I could have like listened to what
they were telling me and swallow
followed it and and and put it into
practice and I could have helped my
brother like I could have been there for
him and instead of like being selfish
and just trying to satisfy my needs and
you know always looking out for me
and uh I could have helped him but again
I abandoned him and I neglected
him you know because it was an
inconvenience to my high and like when
we were kids my
brother like he used to
um we used to fight all the time but he
was like I was like his hero he would um
and we always had each other's backs
like I never let anybody bully him or
mess with him and
uh like when my stepdad was being
abusive to us i' i' I'd be there for him
and I'd be like it's going to be okay
like we don't have to you know we don't
have to be here forever we're we'll get
out of here someday
like
and I I should have been there for him
like and I just left him alone I left my
kid alone and I left my brother by
themselves I'm sure they were wondering
where I
was
so these two people who are always
really sweet to me like my brother
always held me up so high and he always
said he wished that he could do things
the way I do them and I was always so
mean to him when we were little and I
would bully him but I did love him a lot
and I would talk to him and I was always
there for him but then I just stopped I
mean
drugs just made me numb to everyone and
everything it just made me not care
about anyone or anything except for me
and
um my son had never ever done anything
wrong to me my brother and I had fights
and stuff but my son was always so good
and he was always like he was always so
excited to see me like this one time I
went on tour and I was gone for like two
weeks and I came back and he answered
the door and he just looked at me
like and he goes dad I miss you so much
and every time I come and go in and out
out of his life because of drugs every
time I saw him it was like I hadn't even
left it like I'd been there the whole
time he never he never brought it up or
like try to communicate that he was
upset he was just excited to see me and
I was hurting him and his feelings so
bad and making him suffer for nothing he
never did anything to me he was always
so
sweet
and
so I get up and I I leave that trap
house and I just I I had had enough like
I I freaked out and
um I went and
um got a
hotel and I uh stole a bunch of credit
card information started printing checks
I got someone to buy me a couple guns I
bought an ounce of heroin an ounce of
meth and a couple of computers and I was
just on a rampage and I was I was like I
said to myself I'm going to steal as
much money as I humanly possibly can and
I'm going to I'm going to I don't know
what I'm going to do I'm going to make
like a little mini Empire for me and
anybody that tries to mess with me
is going to get it and you know I don't
need anybody and you I don't know I I
know what I was thinking I was just kind
of losing it
so I'm on this Rampage and I fill this
car up that my friend let me borrow with
all this illegal stuff and uh I gave
this girl who's a friend of mine a ride
to the methadone clinic and then I pull
into this neighborhood and
um I just sat there for a second and
that was it I was I decided I'm giving
up like I don't want to do this anymore
I don't I don't want to be here anymore
I'm done
so I was going to shoot myself in the
head and I had this high point
380 um which is a very cheap very
unpredictable very crappy gun that's
notorious for jamming and going off at
random and just not a very good gun so
I'm sitting there and I'm like I can't
die sober though so I've got heroin and
I've got Fentanyl and I've got meth and
I do a hit of each one
and
I uh I get so high that I'm I try to
shoot I'm going to try to shoot myself
but I'm trying to [__] the gun and it
gets jammed so I I hit it a couple times
and finally it goes and it uh it uh I I
was able to [__] it but then I I got
really like the the drugs all set in at
once and I I leaned forward and just
kind of fell slump over and the gun went
off and went up right next to my my head
like and it it it left a little scar on
my ear cuz it just whizzed right by it
was so weird but um the bullet whizzed
right past me and I remember I went whoa
and I said out loud I don't want to do
this anymore I immediately changed my
mind
and yeah the the drugs and the
adrenaline and the shock and everything
just all kind of set in at once and I
fell asleep and uh yeah just passed out
like it was like over amp 101
and I wake up to a cops knocking on my
window and I I remember thinking [__]
here we go again so they open the the
the door cuz they were doing a welfare
check
and
um they see the gun and they freak out
and they pull me out and they put me in
cuffs
and they uh they asked me like what are
you doing out here and I just looked at
the cop and I go I was trying to kill
myself while committing you know dozens
of felonies and I go so whatever you're
doing like just take me to jail please
so I can kill myself there like I don't
want to be here anymore I don't want to
be near this car it's creeping me out
like I don't you know and he goes what
do you mean you were trying to kill
yourself I I tried to shoot myself
that's why the gun went off like and
like I said I don't want to be here
anymore I'll answer any questions you
have just like take me away from this
this car like it's giving me weird Vibes
and he goes okay well come over here
with me and he goes why were you trying
to kill yourself and I go because I just
got stabbed
shot uh in in drug deals gone bad so I
can barely hold myself up I don't have
anywhere to go I don't have any family
because my family won't talk to me
because I'm a junkie I I abandon my son
I abandon my brother who just died and
like I couldn't be there for anybody or
either of them because I was too selfish
and focused on what I had going on
and um yeah I just I want to give up I
don't want to be alive anymore like just
just take me to jail cuz I swear to God
I'm going to hang myself when I get
there and he says
uh do you have anybody I can call to
verify this information with and I go
you want to call and verify that I tried
to kill myself I
go and he goes no just like the
information about your brother and stuff
and I go I mean you can call my mom but
at this point I'm sure she's sick of
hearing from from cops so she'll
probably just hang up on you so he puts
me in the back of his Cruiser and um
he uh gets on the phone and I know he
talked to her because he was on the
phone for quite a while so we get in and
I just assume we're going to jail but
all of a sudden this feeling comes over
me and
um I start praying and I hadn't prayed
in a long time and I don't know what it
is exactly I believe in but I just kind
of remember saying God Universe Buddha
Allah whatevers out there like
whatever's watching down upon me
um I made a mistake and I've been a
really really really terrible person and
I've hurt people that didn't deserve to
be hurt and
um I've been really I've turned into the
exact thing I never wanted to be you
know was neglectful I was selfish I was
abusive I
was yeah all these things that I sore I
would never be and never do I ended up
doing and becoming and
um I said but I really want a chance to
change and I don't want to be this way
anymore cuz I really I almost just
killed myself and if I had killed myself
and I would have been gone forever then
my son would never get to see me again
even though I don't deserve to see him
he deserves to see me like he deserves
to see his father and to be happy and
all he need to do is just get it
together and and really really
be you know there for him because even
though he deserves a good father he
doesn't deserve what I did to him he but
he deserves a good father and I don't
deserve him at
all
but if ID have left he would have just
probably wondered his whole life where I
was and when I was coming back because I
know he would just sit around waiting
for me sometimes like people tell like
he's waiting for you and he just asks
about you all the time like where's Dad
when's dad coming
home
and I just I need to make this right so
please like if by some Divine Miracle
whatever's looking after me like if you
can get me a bond or just find a way for
me to get out of jail like I'm on
probation and parole now at this point
um in two different counties or no I was
just on parole but um
um if you can get me out of going to
jail and not getting a bun like I
will I swear I give my
word I will dedicate my life to trying
to be sober I'm I'm not even going to
sit here and lie anymore I'm not going
to say oh yeah this is it this is
definitely quitting time for me I'll
never do it again cuz that's total hesit
but I will I I do give my word that I
will try as hard as I can to uh
get get and stay sober like I'll make a
real honest genuine effort at it and I'm
just praying for that over and over
please don't take me to jail or if I go
to jail get me a bond and all of a
sudden we we pull up to this building
and um I don't recognize it and we get
out and he said okay so when we get
inside I go wait wa hold on where are we
and he goes we're at the Southwest Visa
hospital and I go what are we doing here
and he goes well I'm taking you to get a
to psyche Val to detox and I goes
so do I go to jail afterward and he goes
I'm not taking you to jail I don't think
jail is the place for you he goes I've
seen your record
um you know jail clearly isn't working
for you it's not helping you get clean
he goes so I'm going to try a different
approach I'd really like to to help you
today and um he goes I think you should
use it because your your mom just lost
one of her kids
you know imagine how she's feeling he
goes I mean I know you lost your brother
but your mom lost one of her kids he
goes and if she lost you too
like you know is that what you want to
do to her and I I said no and he goes so
use this and
um just try to do the right thing and I
just looked at him and I think he knew
what I was doing I was
speaking through him to my mom and to my
brother my son I just looked at him and
I started weeping and I said I'm sorry
I'm so
sorry I'm
sorry and um he goes I know it's okay he
goes just get yourself right you know
and call your mom call your son like
they want to see
you and so I I went to
um I went to a detox
and the the first day I was there like
after the first night of sleep I woke up
in the morning and I called my drug
dealer and I was going to have him come
pick me up and then all of a sudden I
had to get the
address and it's like the need for the
address saved my life
because
I had I I was like I got to leave the
address hang on he goes just call me
back with it and I I hung up and I go up
to the front desk and I said ma'am and I
look at her for a second and all of a
sudden this Moment of clarity washes
over me and um I
said what time is it and she said it's
3:15 and I go thank you and I just
walked off and I didn't call him and so
I called my
mom and she waited for me to get
finished uh so it was like another two
days and she picked me up and she took
me into sober
living and
um I I was in sober living for about a
month and uh I was really getting into
it and
everybody was like don't date for at
least a year don't date for a year
that's that's what they tell you in um
you know the recovery Community if
you're if you're newly sober don't start
dating unless you're already in a
relationship but like if you're if
you're getting sober for the first time
in your life and you're single stay
single but I didn't listen to that rule
so I I was telling myself like I can't
drink I can't do drugs like I can't
gamble like I can't do anything so I
might as well just date you know and I
proceeded to get a dating app which I
had never done before and I met this
girl called
Haley and I was immediately just
instantly drawn to her I was so
attracted her she to me she was just she
was very sexy and very cute at the same
time and uh so we connected and we
started texting back and forth and
she she liked a lot of the same uh music
I
did and she was super cool she was a
little bit younger she's uh almost 10
years younger than me but
um yeah we we went and we had a date and
before we had the date we we kind of did
a a pre pre- interiew preate interview
where I called her up on FaceTime and
she proceeded to tell me that she had
done heroin before for too with her
ex-boyfriend and they did it for a
little while and so she kind of
understood you know what I was going
through and um then she explained that
she
was having some issues with cocaine and
alcohol and
uh so I told her I was you know sober
and that I wasn't doing any of that and
we met for dinner but she ended up
getting blackout drunk and
uh I took her home and uh to make sure
she got home safe and we ended up
hanging out and we stayed up all night
just like chatting
and yeah getting to know each other and
uh I would say like as crazy as it
sounds like we we probably fell in love
with each other officially the first
night we uh we actually hung out cuz
we this attraction I had to her and the
ability to open up and connect was was
like yeah yeah I'd never felt that with
anybody like I was immediately just like
wanting to be so open with her and share
so many things with her
so
um we after that we were inseparable we
we we we we were never away from each
other and a couple weeks goes by and she
goes so I guess I don't drink or do
drugs anymore and I said what why and
she goes well
because um you know I just think it's
the right thing to do and I see you're
not doing this for me are you go because
I'm the one with the problem I'm not
asking you to do this like you don't
need to do this for me like please
understand that she said no I I do but
um from everything you're describing and
like how you've explained alcoholism and
addiction it sounds awfully familiar and
like I'm probably going through that and
she said and I also think it'd be really
[__] up for me to drink or do drugs
around you because you're trying to stay
sober
so we
yeah we were sober we were a sober
couple and it was great for a good while
but then um all of a
sudden
um something happened um
and I found out Haley had been lying to
me about something uh and that really
upset me in a big way the thing is she
lied but at the time I was just being
selfish and I
was you know not allowing her to be
human I was I wanted her to exceed my
expectations and my expectations were
impossible like I guess I was just very
heavily guarded with my um heart and
stuff because I had been screwed so many
times in the past and like my ex-wife
had cheated on me and Julia had cheated
on me and Ella had just up and left me
and like I
figured you know I can't deal with this
again and I thought that that's what was
happening but but it was really just a
case of her being ashamed and
embarrassed about something that she had
done that she didn't want to you know
rock the boat with and she didn't want
me looking at her differently
and so I got really mad though and I
relapsed and I relapsed really bad
and the the thing is
like I I hadn't
like I I I relapsed for about a month
and it was really bad and like for all
the time I had lost being sober I made
up for in that month like you know I was
I was like going to go and make up or
all that lost time uh you know doing
drugs but through everything Haley
stayed with me and she she kept you know
God bless her soul she kept like at me
and she was she was going and looking
for me like she had my location in her
phone and she was going looking for me
in very very dangerous neighborhoods
where there were drug dealers and
gangsters and rapists and murderers and
she was coming to find me and she's you
know maybe 53 or something like that
and you know 5 lb soaking wet
and she just loved me so deeply and
unconditionally that she was willing to
put herself in danger to come and try to
rescue me
and she just she saved my life and in
her I I I saw like these things that had
happened with my my brother and my son
and and I said that like this person is
stuck with me and I don't want to I
don't want to do this again I don't want
to abandon this person that's been so
good to me I'm going to do it right this
time so I went to rehab and
I I I I went to a real rehab now too and
it was so nice and it was like a
vacation was awesome I I couldn't
believe I
hadn't done it years before I wish I had
but and I got out
and
um I just decided to focus on my music
and uh my career
and um I've been sober now a
year and uh with the suboxin
uh no I you know I was doing subox one
in the beginning uh but now I have like
uh I still have a prescription but I I
hardly ever feel it like it usually just
it's the pharmacy uh in the beginning I
I did use it cuz it was hard but um yeah
you know I what's really really helped
me is creativity and music uh I kept I
was every time I would try to get clean
before I would I'd be missing something
like I was like there's something I'm
missing and I think for me now it's i' I
rediscovered my purpose like I know who
I am again you know and I'm a musician
and I struggle like a lot I hardly make
any money you know um I'm always trying
to come up with some cool way to pay the
rent because I have a lot of felonies
and uh I'm trying to get paid to to do
music and I don't have a record deal
anymore so but I mean I feel fulfilled
and I'm
sober and uh you are are you in your
son's life yeah my son uh comes in he he
just stayed with me two weeks and I just
had another little boy uh he's 7 months
so that's great things are a lot
different yeah it's possible yeah
absolutely for anybody who uh wants to
get sober um if I can do it anybody can
because I was really lost and I was
really selfish and really mean and uh I
try not to be any of those things
anymore and um it's taken a lot of work
but it it can uh it is possible how many
years of debauchery were there 20 years
20 how old are you 34 wow yeah I started
around 12 13 but I really it really took
off when I was 14 so 20 years and losing
your brother must have impacted you
greatly oh yeah yeah I I write songs
about him all the time I just wrote a
song as a matter of fact um that I
really like and uh um
it's my my my girl listens to it now and
she's like the lyrics are so sad like
it's making me sad and I'm like good
that's how I feel I miss him all the
time I just I really wish I could hear
him talk just one more time that's if I
could if I could have anything in the
world like if I had one wish I just I
just want to hear him
say one more thing to me it could be
anything but that's all I really want
stay here and one more
time Josh what what would you say is the
most important lesson you've learned in
all of
this the most important
lesson that's going to sound cliche but
love really does conquer all um my
wife's love for me helped me get sober
and my love for music has helped me stay
sober you
know um I didn't love myself
when all this was going on with my son
and my brother and stuff like that
either my wife's also taught me how to
to love myself and that even though I've
screwed up in a lot of ways it's it's
okay and I can fix
it it's a great story thank you I wish
you all the luck in the world now thank
you yeah thank you man appreciate it
thank
you